Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys hit the like button, if you enjoyed the video and yeah, let's begin.
All right, what's going on?
Hey guys, this is Rob and, uh, we are back with venom beyond. Here's the thing,
man. I, I love the way that Dani Kates writes this, right?
Because I fired this book up and I say within the span of five minutes I was
done, right. I just ripped through this book. And to me,
that's a Testament of how good a comic book is, right. If I can just like,
if I find myself just ripping through it and I feel like I'm done before I even
started, that's just how good the kind of book is written. Right? So, um,
this kind of gives us at least as much as Donnie Cates gives us anyway,
the way in which the world fell under the rule of venom sun.
And we're not given a whole ton of stuff here. And in reality,
we probably don't need to be.
But the idea here is that at some point in the past,
and this alternate reality that there was, you basically had, you know, an,
an weighing who of course was possessed by her venom.
Symbion more or less operating as what amounts to agent venom,
alongside Spiderman, who ended up defeating Dr. Octopus, right?
In some campaign that was called octopi wall street, it was kind of goofy,
but an weighing basically reveals that she's pregnant here.
Now this is what's kind of bonkers is Donnie Cates doesn't necessarily seem to
have given us the indication that Eddie Brock is the one who got her pregnant.
It's just simply that Eddie Brock, you know, was Eddie Brock and her were,
were married at one point in a relationship. If we follow the, you know,
a reasonable timeline here,
we don't definitively know when it was that Eddie Brock shot himself.
We're not told here.
And this particular comic that like three days after Eddie Brock shot himself,
you know, we're not really told that instead.
It's just Eddie Brock ended up killing himself in the bell tower.
And then Ann went there and she ended up getting the venom Symbion right.
So we don't really know how much time has passed.
I would expect that under most circumstances,
whenever a woman realizes she's pregnant issues, they,
because as she goes through her womanly times that she realizes that she's not
doing the things she's supposed to be doing. And as a result of that,
we can largely assume that at most a month has passed since Eddie Brock died by
whatever manner and whatever means,
if we assume that Eddie Brock is the one who got her pregnant,
then that make sense. We could also kind of assume that she was,
that it's like a miraculous conception, right?
That like the Symbian ultimately just ended up creating an offspring inside of
her. Uh, again, we're not giving a definitive answer here.
We just kind of have to swing for the fences because when she's sitting down
with Peter Parker and she tells Peter Parker that she's pregnant,
when he asks who the father is, she's like, I don't know.
Now the third option here is that Anne's just really promiscuous.
And like any number of guys out there could be the dad, right.
We just don't know. Right. It's like an episode of Maury Povich, right?
You bring like 20 guys on there. None of them are the father. Right?
You have no idea which one it is, you know? So that's an,
that's also an option to write, but whatever it is, she ended up being pregnant.
And of course that was Dylan, right? She ended up being, you know,
getting pregnant and having Dylan.
The crazy thing about this as Peter Parker basically talks about, Hey, like,
you know, it was going to be tough, being a single mom.
I was kind of raised there,
but if you ever need any help on here and her response is I'm not a single mom,
right. I have been. Um, and so like between the two of us,
we can raise this kid to become a productive member of society. Right.
We'll just be fun, you know, we'll, we'll be just fun.
And so what you end up finding out here is that as time passed and Dylan grew up
and got to the age that he is now in the main Marvel universe,
that he grew up as any kind of a normal kid does, right.
He had his good moments, his bad moments, right. You know, kids misbehave,
they push Brown, uh, push boundaries, different things like that, you know?
And so he did what any normal kid does,
but then one day she came home and all those different drawings were on the
walls, right? The,
the drawings of like the Grenville and that's kind of the telltale signature of
like NOLA Simeot God.
And so what she basically shows here is that at some point along the line,
that Knoll ended up taking over Dylan. Right now, this I believe is shown in,
in, in a one-shot comic that focuses on Noah,
basically getting his hands on Dylan and,
and influencing him and actually teaching him how to use his powers or at least
teaching them the base on how its powers work.
And then the rest was kind of left to Dylan from there.
But one of the things to keep in mind for those of you guys who are a little
behind here, no, the Symbian God was Donnie Cates, his invention.
And what he basically did is he introduced this idea that where Brian,
Michael Bendis had previously given us this explanation of the symbionts and the
sense that venom was not a one-off right.
The venom actually comes from a planet of symbionts and those symbionts are
ideally space nights, right?
So they basically bond themselves to a host and they go forward as protectors of
the universe that sometimes assembly it can be corrupted.
And that's what happened that in the original secret Wars,
Peter Parker came in contact with assembly and he was supposed to be a space
nine of sorts, right?
Like a protector using a Symbian the result was that once he was told by Reed
Richards in the old web of Spider-Man comics,
that the Simeon was an actual Cynthia being under the things that Peter was
doing were basically because of it was acting in acting of its own a court that
Peter cast it off and in doing so that corrupted the venom Simeon.
And that's how it ended up becoming quote unquote, a bad guy,
and then basically bonded itself to Eddie Brock later on.
And that's the whole history of venom in the, you know,
you're on the main Marvel universe.
The idea was that when Donnie Cates came along,
Donnie Kate said everything that Brian,
Michael Bendis said with the planet of the symbions is still intact,
but I'm adding onto it.
And he created no and no was the person who created the symbionts in the first
place. He created them as basically his henchman.
And that once Knoll was ultimately defeated and kind of cast back into the void,
or at least, you know, kind of locked within his own,
his own planet more or less,
and surrounded by all these symbionts symbionts then in turn became more or less
autonomous. And that's when they formed the idea of becoming protectors,
as opposed to henchman of note with no,
basically re-emerging and the aftermath of a,
of absolute carnage that no began to exercise his control over the symbionts yet
again,
that's really where this comes from in the sense that Knoll basically reached
out from his place within the multi-verse and is influenced this version of
Dylan and basically taking him over right.
In the sense that like Dylan now kind of operates seemingly as an agent of note.
And the result of this is that he ended up taking a piece of his mom's Symbian
and then use it to create his own Sybian following that he ended up taking off
to a different location. And this is,
this is kind of us reading between the lines or at least from what,
what Ann's telling us, that he ended up going to the, basically the bell tower.
And then in turn,
started spawning off all these different symbionts and then controlling them and
then rejecting them.
And this was designed for the purpose of him basically creating symbionts and
then kind of you serving as control over those symbionts and sending them
forward and response to this growing symbiont threat president flash Thompson
ended up creating an weighing and the agent venom force more or less.
And in doing that, the idea was to on the forces of Dillon,
the issue here is that by the time they realized that Dylan was literally a
credible threat,
it was simply too late that with these symbionts he had created,
he had basically forced them onto the superheroes and some of the supervillains
and turn them into a Symbian Hitchman.
And so he literally laid waste to virtually any other superhero and villain that
was left, right.
Killed pretty much all the superheroes and all the supervillains on earth,
following that. And with the death of president flash Thompson,
Dylan essentially made himself a dictator, right.
He made himself absolute ruler of the earth and then sent his symbionts around
the world and started basically taking over everybody around them. Right?
Like the average person. And that's, that's,
that's kind of what Anne says is that Dylan killed the world,
that he essentially conquered the world by using venom symbionts.
And that's why this is just a minimized world. Right? All the heroes,
all the villains are all Cypriots.
Now some of these heroes are actually heroes who have been taken over by
symbionts. Some of these heroes are just venom. Symbionts looking like heroes,
right? Like, you know, kind of appearing as these individuals,
it's kind of a mishmash of these different things.
But the long and short of this is that the concern of Ann is that Dylan could
essentially fall down the same way.
And this comes in a couple of different forms.
The first form this takes is her asking Eddie, does Dylan have these powers?
Now keep in mind, this is a highly emotional situation for Ann, because one,
like she lost her son. She lost her son to the power of Noah.
And there doesn't really seem to be a way to bring him back.
The other part of this is that she is kind of emotionally tied to Eddie Brock.
This is not her Eddie Brock,
but this is in a lot of ways kind of the Eddie she could have had. Right.
And a lot of ways they're a mirror for the life that she lost.
And so that's when she asked the question like,
does your son have that same power? And the responsibility is yes,
he can do that. But he won't, he can't really be taken over by symbionts.
It creates a kind of feedback or feedback loop.
And ultimately it causes him pain. But to, he's not an evil guy,
he's not a bad kid. He's not a villain in the way that your son was.
It sucks to say that, but he's not that way.
Now the issue with this is that Dylan over hears everything, right? Like,
like the, the main Marvel universe, Dylan overhears them all. And for him,
it's kind of crushing, right?
It's crushing to hear that this alternate reality version of himself became such
a horrible person, right. That essentially took over the world.
And that there's a concern that he could become that exact same kind of person,
right?
It's like if you were met with an alternate reality counterpart of yourself who
was just a horrible human being and the concern of everybody that you knew is
that you would become that person, right?
There's a part of you that screams out. I'm not that guy.
I'm not going to be that person, but Dylan has never really met his mom,
but he never really met, met Anne. I mean, she gave birth to him,
but like she ran off to, to, uh,
to Eddie Brock's dad and drop the kid off there when he was a baby and then went
and did herself it right. And so he's never actually met his mom and his,
the woman that he sees, you know, that,
that is the closest he ever came to meeting.
His mom has essentially rejected him.
This is emotionally crushing for really all parties involved here.
The caveat to this is that as they're sitting down and as an cut,
it's kind of says, look, I can't really do this. This is too much.
And as she begins to leave, she's met by venom pool and he's like,
you guys have to go. And it's like, why? And he's like,
because they tracked us here. Like they,
they tracked you guys to your base of operations, right?
Like you guys get out of here as fast as you possibly can because they're
sending someone here to take you. And as soon as she, you know,
as soon as Ann calls in the SOS and suddenly you have score, but you know,
pops in.
And I remember Matt Gargan was operating as virus at the start of the story,
right?
He is been main Marvel universe version of Mac Gargan who has basically been
taken over by a Simeon of source. It was given to him by,
or at least impose on him by up by codex, in order to track it down Eddie,
and then bring him to bring him to Dylan.
And then of course kill everybody else. And the issue with this is like,
as soon as, as they show up all hell breaks loose,
the caveat to this is that Eddie Brock is aware that the weakness of symbionts
comes in the form of like a Sonics or huge amounts of electricity or fire.
And so what he ends up doing is grabbing like these live electric lines just
grabs them and reads like, like those are electrical currents, right?
Like no one can survive. Any of that. Any of that kind of energy,
his response is, yeah, that's what we're counting on.
So he basically channels it through himself and shoots it out. And what it,
what the venoms can be creates is a hand cannon and basically takes out Mac,
right, takes out Mac Gargan. Then he, you, he calls him his son do your thing.
And Dylan seizes, the Symbion off of, uh,
off of scorpion takes total control of it.
And then basically Mack argan reverts back to his normal self, right?
This is a genius maneuver,
but it's also exceedingly dangerous because the more that Dylan uses his powers,
the more susceptible to Knoll he becomes,
and that would allow Knoll to reach in. Now, one thing,
if I'm being honest with you guys,
one thing that I think is really kind of going on here is wouldn't it be
interesting if Donnie Cates followed the Jonathan Hickman Avenger's new Avengers
molecule man concept, right. In the sense that during a vendor's a new Avengers,
most of you guys know there was one molecule man in every reality.
And that origin of molecule man was the exact same,
but he was designed to be a bomb that the Bianers were going to detonate all at
the same time and destroy the multi-verse. Right.
But wouldn't it be interesting if it were the same concept with Dylan,
that every universe has its own version of Dylan and Dylan is unique among,
you know, in, in every single universe in the sense that Wallace origins,
not the exact same, although it, it may be in some way that he has these powers,
the ability to dominate the wills of symbionts, he is an effect,
it kind of indirect air to note, right?
He possesses essence of the same powers that Knoll does,
even if not on such a grandiose scale. And that by having that kind of power,
it allows Knoll to basically take over Dylan,
which allows him to control the SIM Gates across every world.
Wouldn't that be interesting, right? Every world in every universe,
but as far as my garden goes, you know, of course when,
when the symbionts torn off of him and Eddie realizes it's Matt Gargan,
do we kind of get a little bit of explanation here, right?
And the idea is that during absolute carnage, but as you guys remember,
Matt Gargan, his spine was almost totally ripped out.
And he was basically paralyzed and Eddie left him there and Eddie just left him
there and you got to go by Leo. He ended up taking off and leaving him there.
And that's why Matt Gargan holds so much animosity because he's like,
you don't forget,
like you don't get to just walk away from the fact that you left me paralyzed
like that.
Now admittedly not guardian was going to let like an innocent kid die. Right.
So, you know, at the end of the day, Eddie Brock's like,
I was kind of right for what I did.
But the response of Mac is you basically left me there.
That way I could have recovered if I'd had a symbiont or something like that,
but I couldn't write, like you just left me paralyzed there and walked away.
And so the response of Eddie and this is really interesting.
The response with Eddie is fine. Then we'll make you a deal,
but I'm going to make you a deal here. My son just killed the Symbian.
That was to you from codex. Right?
So what we're going to do is you're going to take us to codex and then seemingly
the bargain is, you know, I will give you a symbiont or something like that.
And you'll regain your ability to walk. I,
I don't really know what the bargain is,
but the idea is you are going to take us to codex and as will,
seemingly Dylan is going to meet his alternate reality counterpart and who even
knows what's going to come out of that conflict.
I have no earthly clue because maybe we'll get even more of an origin story
about codex, right. And that's why I was kind of tentative here.
Maybe we'll get a lot more information because we still got two issues.
I think until this whole thing is done. So that being said, guys,
we're gonna bring this video to an end. If you are new here to comments,
explain to make sure you guys have the sub button to become part of the Rob
core. If you guys enjoyed this video, make sure you drop a,
like now we'll catch you all later.
Bruce.
[inaudible].